[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir c'est la grande soirée retail de
la téléphonie mobile j'en ai parlé déjà
il ya un petit moment
grande soirée avec plein de monde pour
parler de téléphonie pour parler cinq
étoiles et plein de choses vous saurez
co organisé avec ariel gomez de retail
numérique magazine et moi même
monsieur gros vous le savez vous
regardez la chaîne c'est vous le savez
quand je crie plutôt cool une fois ce
sens qu'elles ont bossé depuis longtemps
j'en avais déjà parlé on travaille
depuis quelque temps déjà sur un très
gros projet sur lequel vous allez
intervenir et je vous avais mis à
contribution pour des votes
en fait l'histoire c'était que vous
votiez dans différentes catégories
il remettait justement les prix de vos
votes bienvenue ça se passe là ça
commence dans quelques instants les
invités commencent à arriver
je pense je pense qu'on fait comme aussi
une excellente soirée
[Musique]
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de votes vous
avez été extrêmement nombreux
extrêmement nombreux je vous remercie
vraiment vraiment cette participation
parce qu'en fait on voulait pas avec
ariel qui est une soirée où nous on dise
ok on choisit telle ou telle marque tel
ou tel smartphone et on remette nos prix
on voulait vraiment vous donner la
parole que ce soit vous qui prenez la
parole et que ce soit vous qui donnez
vos awards vos prix ce soit vraiment
représentatif de la communauté
vous avez été extrêmement nombreux
extrêmement nombreux à voter merci
beaucoup
les résultats ont été donnés hier aux
professionnels j'ai tout noir sur blanc
ici pour pouvoir effectivement vous et
donnez vous dévoiler le résultat du vote
et croyez moi que c'est vraiment hypra
intéressant merci à nos partenaires
comme opposant skill des commerces tous
deux ravis de faire un bel événement
vraiment chouette alors la soirée vous
fait très rapidement
vous avez eu une petite d'ouverture avec
jean maraldi qui est monsieur qualcomm
france passait par un petit peu les
enjeux de la 5g lorsqu'elle arrivait si
vous vous souvenez
sur la vidéo de la 5g à qualcomm à
barcelone j'ai interviewé jean varaldi
et on a pu effectivement parler déjà de
208 m
[Musique]
et ensuite une table ronde autour de la
5g avec olive et gonnet qui est
directeur commercial
omni canal chez sfr denis morel qui est
directeur france de automobile michel
bass au directeur général de bigben
connect
et patrick richard directeur commercial
et marketing de riz commerce groupe
appris plein de choses sur les enjeux de
la saint-jean reparlera de l'aca ne
l'honore pas parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'enjeu et même bien plus qu on peut le
voir une croix rouge ou jaune les
résultats des votes c'était vraiment
hyper intéressant est plein
d'enseignements à retenir première
catégorie qu on a présenté ses la
catégorie du meilleur rapport qualité
prix à moins de 300 euros y avait
beaucoup de smartphones enjeu est celui
qui a gagné le lauréat c'est pas très
surprenant c'est le chili lors m me nots
est un écran lcd avec une diagonale de 6
3 pouces vous avez double module photo à
l'arrière 48 mégapixels sony mx 5 186 je
prends que leurs amis de
fonctionne très bien dans le top10 un
produit on a beaucoup parlé sur la
chaîne que j'ai souvent conseillé lors
des faq et vous avez été 40 2% à choisir
leurs épines autre secte dont beaucoup
les faits ça soit je suis bien au
deuxième une catégorie c'était le
meilleur rapport qualité prix
à moins de 600 euros en donnant un petit
peu le tarif est aussi très intéressant
en termes d'enseignement parce qu'il ya
vraiment deux produits qu'ils se soient
un petit peu
fight et pour aussi devant une telle
arrivée le premier est celui qui arrive
le premier
seven place avec le wild place cet été
j'aime beaucoup le toucher verre dépoli
son smartphone je trouve ça très doux et
surtout ça laisse absolument aucune
trace de doigt dans cette unité d'abord
aventure en place conclut grandes années
à venir en 2001 et on a hâte d'être
présent sur ici l'année prochaine
également
on a tous les deux envie ce faire
effectivement mais est souvent
recommandée du coup vous avez été très
nombreux et nombreuses publicités autour
des parties dans le meilleur design la
catégorie de plus beau design est en
fait le produit qui est sorti à 30
points à 2 6% et très intéressant parce
qu'il a un design complètement atypique
novateur c'est le galaxy phone de
samsung
là vous avez vraiment du confort pour
regarder des séries des films jouer et
ça c'est vraiment révolutionnaire jeu
hélas
nous les mobilités en jeu
donc traverser de nouveau qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas c'est vraiment prix qui
est très novateur qui est très différent
qui ouvre la voie en tout cas au smart
s'inquiète donc c'était vraiment cool de
voir comment son nouveau design a pu
vraiment retenir votre attention pour
vous puissiez aller voter dessus
catégories suivantes c'est le smartphone
ayant le meilleur écran alors les
beaucoup de produits qui ont été
plébiscités
il y en a deux qui se battaient vraiment
tout d'un coup tu pourras la place qu
l'héroïne et souhaitait gagner c'est le
samsung le galaxy note 10 plus zava
d'écran si ces biens publics ou des
diagonales
moi je trouve vraiment bien les ans de
visionnages sont vraiment cool que vous
n'étiez d'un côté ou de l'autre
elle va vivre son départ de l'école
gestion de m
tu sais qui c'est mon grand âge
sur la ligne avec l'écran écope ensuite
catégorie c'est le meilleur smartphone
en photo là c'est pareil vous avez eu à
l'e3 produits qui se battent un petit
peu et celui qui a gagné c'est le p 30
pro de mourir je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte
mais regardez bien ce qu'on est en train
de voir la la ça correspond à sa là
parce que vous avez ici de défendre on
doit qui passe devant
ça c'est ça et ça c'est les os x 50 et
ça c'est vraiment très très très
impressionnant
et il n'est achetée par ce manque
d'essence aux états des as et ouais
c'est dans un communiqué
je vais aller
histoire pour en acheter plus malgré ça
on l'a réussi en france fonctionnent à
ses performances exceptionnelles et
profond soit l'exigence hk jammer très
particulière merci à vous
c'est vrai qu'ils voient plus leurs mecs
un produit moi c'était vraiment vraiment
chouette en ce temps des partenaires et
catégorie le smartphone le plus
performant on allait préciser vitesse du
processeur mémoire stockage autonomie et
5 sans surprise c'est une bête de
compétition à retisser un smartphone que
j'ai pu tester un smartphone qui énorme
en termes de capacités de calcul c'est
l'europe phone de 2 à zoug lors le
modique c'est en gros le mode ultra
performant ce qui va pousser la machine
à fond
vous allez consommer davantage de
batterie n'est par contre de la route
complètement incroyable une machine
vraiment sûr booster
mais eux
les présents on l'aimé
paris est simple
mme ben ali en revanche est con
très beau produit kosten très complet si
vous aimez le des ministres ex un
produit qui paraît cool on est parti en
souvient catégorie innovation dans
l'accessoire en fait c'était catégorie
la plus généraliste dans l'accessoire
autour de la téléphonie mobile que ce
soit de la trottinette la tête de force
n'ouvre la mise parce que vous les
reposer votre smartphone dessus il se
recharge à induction peut aussi de le
recharger directement avec un câble que
ce soit de la boîte collector il ya
beaucoup d'accessoires et celui qui a
tiré son épingle du jeu c'est la galaxie
watch actif de 2 samsung moderne qui
actuelle avec un beau design avec
beaucoup de possibilités de
personnalisation et ça c'est vachement
bien
les lecteurs du quotidien que j'ai aussi
beaucoup aimé que tous les produits
total a cédé produisez vous voulez mais
je n'ai pas voté donc ça c'était
chouette ensuite meilleur coques de
protections hors marques de
constructeurs on parle bien et qui
manquent de coke de smartphones je
dirais que sans surprise sur ma chaîne
c'est rhinochill qui a sorti les coques
de rhinau shide ce qui suit regardez-moi
ça ça comme c'est mignon
vous prenez vous les glisser
délicatement à l'intérieur et là vous
avez un smartphone protégé qui ne craint
absolument rien de la part de toute
l'équipe
on vous remercie infiniment de vote
merci à toi également rien pour ton
professionnalisme et son soutien ça nous
fait vraiment plaisir et ça nous motive
pour la suite
en parlant de la suite pour 2020
beaucoup de nouveautés chez réno chine a
annoncé avec 76 3% des votes c'est
énorme
ensuite la catégorie protection
logiciels pour smartphone parce que
c'est bien d'avoir un smartphone les
protéger c'est mieux ça peut éviter
certaines déconvenues et bien c'est
havas avec la solution mobile sécurité
antivirus qui est ressorti et on arrive
ensuite dans les catégories des
opérateurs téléphoniques une première
c'est meilleure qualité perçue au niveau
de l'internet mobile
c'est orange qui arrive est numéro 1 des
47 1% des voix et ensuite c'est la
meilleure qualité d'appel perçu
également orange avec 44,9
on sent des voix donc voyez c'est plein
d'enseignements c'est vraiment hyper
intéressant le devoir effectivement
quels sont les produits qui sont sortis
lesquels est un petit peu au coude à
coude
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'était
vraiment chouette c'est une toute
première édition de toute première
soirée pour moi c'est un exercice qui
était tout nouveau de retrouver sur
scène face à beaucoup de monde
face à des professionnels prendre la
parole en général je suis plus dans
l'audience en train de filmer d'assister
à des conférences que des tracteurs sur
scène j'ai vraiment vu la difficulté
d'être sur celle de prendre la parole
devant beaucoup de monde qui vous écoute
c'était vraiment chaud et une soirée
passionnante beaucoup de discussions sur
la 5 gt de pouvoir voir tous ces
professionnels réunis au même endroit
autour de cet événement autour de vos
votes et que je puisse moi me faire la
voix le porte parole des votes vous ai
fait transmettre vos résultats
j'ai trouvé ça juste génial est ce que
vous voulez pour commencer ça vous
intéresserait qu'il y ait d'autres votes
dans le futur
et une fois de plus la parole et que moi
je puisse transmettre vos voix me faire
le porte parole de vos voix directement
au niveau des professionnels
dites moi ça j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé
cette soirée et je tiens à remercier
tout particulièrement ariel c'était
pendant la soirée mais je leur ai fait
également la de m'avoir proposé de
travailler ensemble pour cette soirée là
de me faire confiance c'était vraiment
ultra ultra il pourra it right right
regardez-moi ça comme c'est chouette la
grande soirée retail de la téléphonie
mobile
c'est vraiment vraiment chouette merci à
vous pour vos votes y avait un concours
également pour gagner des lots pour les
participants on va contacter les
participants très rapidement par email
pour leur signifier qu'ils ont gagné on
leur enverra leur lot très très très
rapidement le temps de sortir un peu la
tête de l'eau joue vraiment faire cette
vidéo très rapidement la faire à chaud
le lendemain de la soirée parce que je
suis encore un peu dans l'événement et
ça me permet vraiment de mon transcrire
ce qui s'est passé comme ça donc vous
inquiétez pas on va revenir tous les
gagnants extrêmement rapidement merci à
vous une fois de plus d'être présent
d'avoir répondu présent ont été très
nombreux très nombreuses d'avoir répondu
à l'appel pour effectivement participé
voter c'est ypres un choix dites moi si
ça vous intéresse pour commencer vous
marquent tout ça en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler de teck je vous
embrasse bout de l'amour
à bientôt ciao